he is an international superstar a
lightweight in the ufc it's patty the
baddie aka the fifth beatle on this
week's food truck diaries and i'm phenom
wago
burgers let's go
[Music]
super thick
[Music]
how you doing brother i'm good i'm good
what's up you look good man you got a
nice little glow about you yeah because
i literally san diego bronzy haven't i
yeah i tell you what if you would have
told me i'd be doing a food truck with
patty the baddie in san diego i would
have called you a liar what what the
hell are you doing out in san diego man
well my manager lives out here and i've
been here i've come out here a couple of
months back and got some good saying and
then with the in studio 540 with j flow
so come back to do the same again level
up once again and enjoy the nice weather
enjoy the swim show yeah enjoy your
victories a little bit and just kind of
get some
do you do you get tan yeah like do i get
a nice town to be honest like nice dude
i got a nice tunnel all right
i haven't had any sun since i was last
here in november so
it's it's much needed to be honest with
that little bit of vitamin d i bet you
yeah coming from liverpool you guys
don't have great weather no we have the
worst weather like
ever i can't even explain how bad the
weather is though it's not like
snowing in that all the time but
it's always raining yeah you get the
weather app says oh it's going to be
sunny this day and then it's not it's
hail stolen but i think because of the
bad weather it's same with like in
russian stuff that's why you guys are so
goddamn tough that's why so much talent
because you got nothing else to do but
fight each other yeah you fight each
other drink tea fish and chips and [ __ ]
wine gums it's not fish and chips why is
that salt and pepper chicken salt and
pepper chicken everyone loves salt and
pepper
is that new yeah
last 10 years at least like 20 years i'd
say salt and pepper chicken and
liverpool's a mainstay oh really salt
and pepper chicken
so fish and chips is old school
um yeah it's a bit old-school like
that's definitely fish and chips
obviously but yeah that's the only kind
of fish i like just fishing bottles like
a grilled mahi
out in san diego though we gotta do we
gotta open the world up to you we got
some good sushi don't like salmon don't
like cod don't like it nice to me so i
wish i liked them because let me diet
and life would be so much easier yeah i
just have to stick to
chicken and steak kind of boring kind of
bone but since your last fight i mean
it's all over you know all over the mma
side you put on some weight you're the
liverpool thick boy yeah a lot it just
happens i can't even help it i say i
think yeah because i feel like you know
what yeah that's that's just my appetite
i'm not
i don't even feel like i'm overeating
sometimes because i still feel hungry
i can't help it i'm fine you went from
55 to what
that's
bro when we walked up i was like is he a
middleweight like you you're but you
felt like you're like
like
fat like flubby like no i've got a
little bit of a belly rather than me
cheeks go massive but i'm not like fat
forward no you're not fat take it all me
straight i'll laugh it off now what i
mean chris because it makes me laugh but
so do you you know let's say i don't
know 190 maybe yeah something like that
well i haven't i haven't weighed myself
since i've got here oh
the heaviest that was was like 204.
yeah but like i hadn't seen him for like
three days and i was eating copious
amounts of food right after your victory
yeah so and i can i thought i'd be about
119 i wanted five tops and what are we
eating just whatever you want like
what's your what's your go to so-so
are you a sweet guy i love to say it's
like yeah
chocolate
chocolate fudge cake cookie dough
cookie dough pie cheesecake we went to
cheesecake factory to the day
cheesecake pancake we had to take some
really good wrestling especially in san
diego man yeah good restaurants here la
is great salted caramel cheesecake
though with all the old milkshakes it's
nice
and your sweet guy what about like wine
gums and if not more than chocolate man
but the chocolate in the states is
not as good as the uk yeah your
chocolate yeah like the chocolate in the
uk is unbelievable like i don't really
that's one not good what one thing
what's good about comes to san diego i
don't eat much sweets or chocolate or
not like that because i can't eat sugar
yeah shite swedish fish are nice i like
them swedish i love sweet red fish yeah
put the chocolaty is just the only thing
about similar is obviously the reese's
but we have that in the uk now you and i
would be trouble if we hung out if i was
in liverpool we would get so fat
together oh a lot it'd be fun but it'd
be problems if i eat more like to be
honest i eat more food and liverpool
than i do yeah right like the sun
there's another fact
yeah and then
i don't know i just know where to go in
liverpool i know what i'm getting away
from yeah exactly yeah
i can just come and feast on whatever i
feel like how have you been handling the
the fame obviously you know i was
talking to your manager you're huge in
liverpool oh in england you know you're
huge man mass about you tom cruise
with a beatles haircut you know
you're the fifth beatles by yourself
yeah and then in the states are you
getting recognized on the streets here
yeah it was a
in liverpool it's i said like the thing
is said to brisbane scouters don't get
enough doubts i said that in an
interview in 2016 when i got rocked in a
fight so like ever since that i said
that in 2016 i'd be getting asked for
pictures in liverpool but then obviously
yeah as the kitty has progressed like it
was weird when it came in november
because we went to new york as well and
like it's in a restaurant a whole yard
house people are coming over asking me
for the picture welcome to times square
fellas coming over asking me for the
picture in times square i'm just like
mad this but obviously it's it's a new
level again but it's going to do that
after every fight i don't know what it
is so i'm yeah i was gonna tell you not
that you don't know this for your
manager to know this like this is just
the strategy yeah this is just the staff
this is just the beginning that's what's
crazy it's gonna get bigger and better
and bigger and better and i can't wait
yeah because you check all boxes you
know what i'm saying you check all you
know fun you're exciting you speak well
you know you have this personality i
think people vibe with so you check all
the box so it's just getting started for
you you know i i think too
you know
it is going to get bigger you're doing
all this press do you feel any pressure
though to deliver every time you know
what i'm saying like you're known for
like you know you're fun you say some
crazy stuff like fun stuff and you're a
confident dude
but it's not like uh like it doesn't
come off as like this crazy ego or like
cockiness like i feel like you truly
believe it no not on with me scripted
love i'm just
i'm just myself yeah and
if people don't like it people like it
i don't care if you don't like me don't
like me but even though you like me i
know you'll still buy a car to watch me
fight on it to watch me get beat it's
like you're about to mean that that's
always not matters now bums on seats and
pay-per-view sales and yeah clicks on
the internet that's all that matters
because then that's where the dollar
signs come in yep
yeah and i think too
you know i was very aware of you all the
the cage worry guys you know there's
such a legacy you know darren tale
connor aspinall
hardy bisping like
you know all those superstars that come
from your area are all out of cage
warriors you know these monsters so i'm
familiar with cage warriors super
familiar with you and
i kind of you know as hardcores we're
just waiting for you to sign with ufc
now that we don't love cage warriors but
you know ufc's the the big dog in town
so your first fight
um
you know you destroyed the guy and then
when it was ufc in london after the
pandemic which was nutsos
you know i
i'll be honest you know you can call me
a wanker what the hell you guys call it
i didn't realize how big you were
already over there i knew you were like
a big prospect and like the night you
know everyone's like next con or
whatever
but then on my show i go you know
there's you such thing as ufc jitters
and fighting your hometown you know ufc
london sold out arenas to be a big deal
but your fans are like nombre he's used
to this this isn't nothing new he could
sell that thing out himself whether it's
with the ufc or not i was like oh damn
my bad i didn't realize yeah you're such
a big deal before you get to the big
leagues i've sold the venus out in
liverpool
with cage audios yeah without the ufc
name attached to it yeah so i know for
the fact i'd set a lot of two out on my
own i could sell out the stadium and
liverpool was on my own i know for the
fact that i agree yeah i also i don't
think ufc london would have sold out if
you went on the car
i thought to be honest
i'm like i think it i think it would
have sold out but it wouldn't have it
wouldn't have sold out in two minutes i
agree i said that to you
said months ago you can't do the alto
arena with me on it without being big
edited and sounded like i'm the big i am
that venue was too small to have me on a
card yeah you could have a boxing style
card with just the main event me and
then loads of crabs underneath me and it
would still sell out yeah i'd see again
i do
i don't and i don't think the audience
or the fan base is getting this confused
as being cocky i just the other day it's
also just a numbers game yeah you've
proven you can do it and i i think you
know you're in such a weird
kind of predicament when it comes to ufc
because they've had big guys i've seen
conor came over
but
it's not to this magnitude you know i'm
saying where you already have this huge
fan base you can sell the arenas
yourself
but at the end of the day you're still
you know
newer to the ufc so they do treat you
like that for now yeah you know even
though you're selling out you're on the
main card and stuff like that but you're
still treated like the new guy how do
you feel about that
what are you gonna do i don't mind love
yeah
i'm taking everything a step at a time
i'm not getting ahead of myself i'm not
like you see some fights are coming and
i have two fights or one fight like i
don't want to fight the champ
yeah you get people what come in and say
i don't want to fight the champ after
the fight and i want to do this you've
seen people saying it lately other at
different weight classes but i'm not one
of them i'm not going to be like hard i
want to fight him now um
i'm taking every inner step at a time i
don't need to rush and fight rank ranked
contenders
it's just not something i need to do
well take it one step at a time i'll
take each fight one step at a time and
eventually i will take the belt and
eventually i will be getting called the
best in the world let's take a little
break from chatting with the fifth
beatle paddy pimlet a little break here
now this ad is not for patty he has
fantastic care for god's sakes this kid
patty just close your ears as you're
watching this this is not for you this
is for those other bros out there losing
their hair you know what i'm talking
about i see at the meet and greets on
tour
you know i'm i'm in uh freaking
charlotte coming up in philly and san
francisco and san diego i'm all over and
i know one thing i can bank on when i
meet the bros a lot of y'all losing your
hair man how about this two out of three
men will experience some form of hair
loss by the time they're 35 that's right
dude 35.
my boy mike right here losing his hair
man he didn't listen to me i said dude
you need keeps keeps man keeps off a
simple affordable and stress-free way to
keep your frickin hair it's convenient
virtual doctor you meet with them all
right and then the medications show up
straight to your house little discreet
package nobody needs to know man you
don't have to leave your home no way in
line at the pharmacy know that stuff
it's 2022 dude you have to go to the
pharmacy man we have 24 7 care and
support all right it's low cost
treatments start just 10
a month all right and keeps getting off
of this because they offer generic
versions all right
so keeps has everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door discreet
little package proven results remember
prevention is key treatments can take
four to six months to see results so act
right now if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss and look like patti
pimblett go to keeps.com shop that's
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash shob s-e-h-a-u-b
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's keeps.com job
s-c-h-a-u-b to get your first month free
keeps.com shop now let's get back to the
show yeah it's a marathon not a sprint
exactly no and i think
you know when i love demetrius johnson
he he came out on a show and he's like
yeah like patty talented dude but you
know he's that you know he's asking for
more money to fight these top ranked
guys like when i was fighting you just
fight those guys it's like
yeah dj i love you but it's also like
same but you're it's
that's such an old-school way of
thinking yeah and that's why you guys
have the issues mighty mouse is in my
top five of all time like i'm upset
no disrespect
you're the flyweight you probably would
take 12 and 12.
what i mean that's what flyweights do
yeah if you get told to eat [ __ ] and eat
[ __ ] yeah lightweights don't yeah i want
to be it's that simple yeah agree 100 i
just think you know it's just the
changing of the guard too like you're
seeing more guys speak out sugar shawn
you yeah because you guys come from a
different background because you know
you're worth and also for the first time
i think ever in the history of the sport
there's a number of guys i don't list
all of them but
you know a number of guys who are making
more outside of the octagon than they
are inside that gun so now you guys have
leverage you know where you can go
that's included that's including me i
made more money outside of sugar
it makes me laugh when people are
commenting on my stuff and things saying
uh he's not active enough he doesn't
fight enough he only he should be
fighting four times a year
why
why should i fight four times a year
give me a reason when i'm in and more
outside the caves and i am in it
you've earned that
yeah you've earned that but also you'll
see with the the mma fanbase especially
ufc fanbase there's going to be pressure
on you to oh we want to see you against
this top five guy this top 10 guy
i mean you know
your badger definitely knows he's
dealing with his background you just
gotta not
ignore all that they're they're gonna
want to see you against the champ i've
had people treating me in the past few
weeks saying oh we want to see him face
making sure if we want to see him face
ferguson yeah we want to see him vs katy
i'm like what
i'll be fighting them for about three
years or something let's chill out and
that's if they're still at the top of
the game by then yeah but then i mean
then like there's no point no that isn't
but also you're just getting started
there's again it's there's no sprint
here
you have a long career man you got smart
people around you you're gonna be fine
man the fans don't always see that
though dude they're just like i don't
want to see this i want to see that and
you can understand it like you want to
see do you want to see fights don't
there's a fight [ __ ] i get it they want
to see you versus other really popular
fighters but they're also the same
people who buy tickets and they're
sitting there going rip his head off
yeah all right well
all right the one i always get is we
want to see your fight sugar showing
o'malley and i'm like
that's 20 pounds you know yeah how are
we meant to fight i could never make 145
again it's not happening it's not
happening
you're going the other way yeah i'm
going the other way yeah goals are 170.
so
there's no way that fights happens but
it still gets treated to me multiple
times a week they just don't understand
it both you guys are kind of in a simmer
lane where he's so polarizing so popular
even outside the octagon yeah and you're
the same so it's like for them it's like
oh this makes sense yeah it doesn't
those things are way bigger that's way
big like way bigger though
way bigger you and i would have a tussle
right yeah it's gonna be a problem you
choked me out to be a [ __ ] tussle
well i don't want you to get over 200
pounds but i am going to feed you some
good food man this is this this game
recommended this looks heavy dude i've
been as we said for about four years now
and
we it's where we do destination food
trucks yeah so i have to you know in la
i have my connection on food trucks san
diego i'm not from here i don't so i
went on said hey i didn't tell people
you were coming on and go hey we got a
big guest i need a food truck in san
diego i would say we got 150 requests to
go oh get swagu it's our favorite food
truck yeah here's swaggy so i'm feeding
some swaggy burgers man but you can't
eat like seven of them right i don't
want to be responsible for the ufc cause
you're in short
see that's another one i won't be taking
those short notice fights that's what's
gonna say what's that happen i don't
need to take a short notice fight all
these people that need to jump on
opportunities with fingernails
you don't take them short notice fights
i don't need to i'm a big enough star as
it is without taking fights on seven
days notice and killing myself like a
crab yeah you don't need them i don't
need you to love i don't need to take
short notice fights so when people say
to me i should take this fight on short
notice why
[Laughter]
all right brother what do you recommend
man well i think today you guys should
try out our el swagador
we do two four ounce wagyu beef patties
two slices of pork belly house-made
secret sauce house-made pickles
house-made serrano peppers and smoked
onions
all on a specialized i'll have that but
with no veg
no peppers no onions no
no not all meat
just meat just fill it with pure meat
what do you think about a three by three
three patties yeah a little bit more
yeah
that's the patty special yeah let's do
it
yeah three patties for the patty daddy
yeah
i'm not the i'm not even trying to hate
on your uh el swagga door uh i'll
probably do the signature swag you just
because i don't i don't mess with pork
really yeah yeah
religious thing i just don't like pork
would
all right thanks brother get that
started for you yep
[Music]
standing
[Music]
[Music]
listen patty is the original liverpool
thick boy and this ad he could use and
this is how i got my thick career
started on the peloton bike that's right
peloton i was working out in my garage
on the peloton doing the 15 minute 30
minute classes sweating i'm talking i'm
burning a thousand calories dude and it
was so much fun the variations i went
let's take this to the streets and
that's when the thick boy bike club
started it all started with peloton you
don't need to go to the gym you don't
need to be worried about getting hit by
cars on your road bike know that stuff
do it from your garage do it from your
office you got time man and they
peloton's never been better because
they're pushing you further like never
before with peloton plus bike the pelton
regular bike new classes new music new
ways to keep your workouts fun and
motivating
listen i've been a peloton member for
six years my username on there is uh
thick boy prez prez with a z all right
you can find me on there see the work
i'm doing they also offer boxing now
that's right boxing no gloves needed
footwork get your grind on the sweat on
from some of your favorite trainers you
know the trainers on there robin's my
personal favorite the trainers on there
are so much
fun and also the music you want to keep
going the music you'll be burning
calories and 30 minutes go by you don't
even know because you're jamming to your
favorite music whatever you're into pop
rock hip hop edm they have over 100
artists series to choose from all right
and uh also working out is easier when
you've got a variety you're not doing
the same thing you can mix it up all
right you can do 30 minutes of strength
20 minutes of cardio do a quick 15
minute total body class a 15 minute
freaking hit class whatever you want man
we got you you got workouts on the bike
yoga meditation dance cardio boxing all
right all you got to do is visit
onepelton.com to learn more that's
onepeloton.com o n e p e l o t o n dot
com now let's get back to patty
all right patty what's going into this
bad boy you got three patties over there
yeah the pockets i mean we couldn't
bring on the food truck show go on don't
go wrong yeah that's what it is go out
or go home a bunch of patties for the
baddie
hopefully this is a good burger man
they're doing their great food it looks
nice
hot tubby
oh yeah
not savvy that's fantastic
hey real quick when you say heavy does
that mean good i don't know the lingo
does heavy mean like good oh good i
think they're like heavy like it's gonna
be like no
in the pill heavy can mean
several things oh really yeah i'm gonna
start using it what else it's a
universal one really
like
say something happened to you made a bad
thing your heart was heavy that wasn't
it that makes sense oh there's some food
all right debbie that's gone oh wow
that's dope i like the lingo
good burger though for yeah fatty good
i'm telling you man uh food trucks in
america especially california that's
what we do
that's restaurants quality though oh
yeah
yeah like this one came so highly
recommend i figured it'd be good all day
that's restaurant quality mm-hmm
i couldn't send you back liverpool
eating bad food man
you've been funny if there's a sushi
trap i mean
you just want to be no i don't like it
yeah not your thing
so
when you talk get back to fighting
you know after you've taken the ufc by
storm you're doing your thing in cage
warrior
if there's going to be any criticism on
patty the baddie in the ufc and you tell
me
your perspective on this it's that you
got hit in your first two fights
yeah
now i think tell me if i'm wrong i think
one of the reasons you got hit is
because you're trying to take the guy
out and you're willing to get hit to get
the finish yeah that was definitely the
face i think it's more calculated yeah i
don't think you're
getting hit and being so i don't think
it's a surprise that you got hit
so i always say that i need to i need to
stop doing it really but
for years
i've always said that my coach says it i
need to take a punch to wake up
paul's always said it i need to get hit
to wake up and you go back and watch on
me okay julius fights what happens in
several of them i get it
and then i i wake up and stuff don't get
going yeah
that's what it was in the last fight
and in the first fight i was just in in
the first ufc fight as you say i think
that was just i wanted to get him out of
there i was going forward with reckless
abandon i didn't really care i knew he
couldn't knock me out so i didn't i
didn't mind taking the shots or two yeah
yeah i figured it was more calculating
you know i think it's more of just you
being entertained trying trying to get
the guys out there as far as you getting
hit every fight i think at some point
you're coaching by great man we can't
get hit every single fight you know what
i'm saying if you have to wake up
hopefully you know yeah although i would
never get to that stage but
i don't think it will i know
i've got good fights iq i'm not theft i
know when
i'm taking too much damage and i'll try
and take the fight to the floor
like i'm not brand new i've been doing
being fighting pro since 17. yeah so
this is all i've ever done about 21 pro
fights and you've had 21 pro fights yeah
damn i've had 30 fights all together
with amateur yeah
you have some fights on you yeah god
damn i don't have that much experience
not just since i was 16. so
so you you got right into it and is it
is it true uh a rich franklin fight got
you into the fc was it rich franklin
belfort yeah vitor vitor being over them
um
i went for the run after that lad like 6
a.m in the uk i went for the run
was that inspiring to you yeah it was
just sick to watch but a couple of weeks
earlier watch diego sanchez with clay
guida in the youth club and i was like i
need to try this and then obviously i
watched the rich franklin belvoir fight
damn what youth club did you go to
they're playing these ufc fights okay
now there was just a little there was
just a computer in there and one of my
mates
kyle wilson he got it up and showed us
it and i was like i need to try it at me
and then i started watching prague
yeah man my favorite fighter probably to
this day is still big knock big knock
yeah he has a really good right hand
yeah he's like
in front of me i just used
really good right here especially fine
in brazil
really i've been watching him shop
though oh yeah we were just getting
battered for like 50 minutes you broke
his neck yeah and then submit him and
you're just like wow he's a badass yeah
he's a badass no he's a legend yeah
super legend
so but did you like with your background
grow up and did you grow up like were
you an aggressive kid were you street
fighting like no
son no i'm not i wasn't a sleep fighter
i wasn't i was never a sleep fighter i
had a few fights when i was a kid and
like who didn't but it wasn't like your
thing right yeah like i didn't really go
around fighting with people it wasn't he
seemed like a cool customer i just never
i got into mma of 15 started training at
the age of 15 and
from then on it just you just knew it
was for you yeah literally when i had my
first fight
i just knew that's what i was meant to
do as soon as you act out yeah because
i've done tournaments before that but
what to say as soon as i've done that
face fighter amateur fighter i won it i
was like i this is what i meant to do
and you just left like i think you're
super fortunate too because being that
young finding your passion early yeah so
that's what's at last yeah yeah a lot of
people are and
luckily enough i walked and i know the
data walked in the gym the 20th of
january 2010
i walked in the gym started training and
14 months later i had my first fight
and then like another
15 months after that i was turning pro
and then when you went into the gym was
it did you focus on uh jiu jitsu or was
just overall
just saying everything everyone for the
first month
i didn't do any striking
because
uh you'll know this one lad anyone who's
never seen don't know this one
i never had any boxing gloves so i had
to get up here from the corner and he
[ __ ] stunk he went monkey they would
discuss them so for the first moment
like sores yeah for the first month i
just done wrestling jujitsu the whole
time and then i got my own pair of
gloves because i had to save up to get
up here yeah and then started doing the
cycling classes as well but you
gravitate towards jiu jitsu yeah like
you really have really high level jiu
jitsu yeah like my jiu jitsu is a bit
weird
could never train for it same for me
i have a different
weird style of jiu-jitsu to anyone else
you couldn't you couldn't get anyone to
come in and replicate me inspire them
around especially how weird me striking
is because i don't do it i was gonna say
you're striking i don't do not unlike
anyone else i'm a weirdo
by design
so when your coaches hold mid it's just
a it's just a bit of a [ __ ] show like
you just like like is there
no there's always a plan but then when i
get into a fight i like fighting yeah
i
there's always a game plan there's
always obviously you want to look the
best you've ever looked but
i like fighting
what i mean i don't mind getting punched
in the face it's not that bad
i'd rather get punched in the face and
still be little toe on a corner yeah i
feel you all i mean well i'll get
punched in the face
and did you is your family on board with
all this
mom dad
everyone's all for it yeah well probably
because you know they're freaking
paddy's freaking mom and dad's are
walking around liverpool yeah my mom's
joining free eggs and [ __ ] my mum's only
ever been to one phase and i lost i
should never come again
she went to the one you lost oh you've
lost a bunch of fights give him one time
i've only lost to the outer thirty
fights and he won't come to one what i
lost and she was heartbroken
she'll never oh my god
my mom came to one it was my first pro
fight and i you know beat this kid up in
like 34 seconds and i see her in the
back and she goes how many were you at
tonight you know what she was telling me
where you got tonight i went that's it
mom this is good i can get touched she
goes oh no no i'll never come again
there's so much of a hassle never came
my again comes every fight
with us with his twin my uncle and
most of the time they don't watch
they're just like
too nervous too nervous
the other week he actually watched
in the o2 and they were both just like
did they realize like when you walked
out when that crowd went freaking nuts
when you hit the yeah
they they realized they didn't realize
how big it actually was yeah they didn't
know before that they didn't realize how
big it was before they didn't realize
like
just the magnitude of everything and
then shin stuff you do it's just
is it weird to you how big you are is it
a little strange to you no
it's just normally yeah you don't see me
i always show it coming really go back
and get podcasts or interviews or
anything when i'm 15 16 17 years old
but i'm just like an amateur or i'm just
saying pro and i say all the same things
yeah i'm going to be the biggest star in
the sport
and it's happening yes it's coming to
fruition yeah um i've been saying it for
over 10 years
it's pretty cool man it's pretty
freaking cool so
going to your next fight any idea when
you want to fight like what's the plan
again you mentioned earlier like after
you make all this money outside the
octagon so there's no pressure but you
know you still gotta they kind of go
hand in hand you want to fight that kid
yeah they want to fight to keep things
wrong but as i said as i've just said
i just genuinely like fighting mm-hmm
i
don't know what it is like if if no one
else got paid and everyone was doing it
for three
five for three yeah
but everyone else everyone else is
getting paid and soon be glad some of
them are getting paid they're worth yeah
i'm not getting paid my way
so there's no point in brushing back
into the cage and
honey burgers like this and
sit and chill
with people like yeah
have a good time yeah man what do you
know about how many calories i've got i
need today and how many strain sessions
i've got to get in
yeah for only being 27 having two fights
in ufc i think you have the best
attitude towards this profession i've
seen you don't seem stressed out a lot
of guys are you know it's tense man so
if you can't it's an intense job man
you're fighting grown men in your
underwear in a steel cage it's like an
intense job when you think about it
i think you're born to do this man
that's what i say i've always said i was
born to do this
i genuinely think of reincarnation as a
thing than thousands of years ago i was
in a coliseum yeah fighting in front of
people to entertain them kill some [ __ ]
yeah killing [ __ ] lions and tigers
and bears are your dicks hanging out
but
like that's genuinely what i think i
know i always put on this af to do this
i was put on the show to fight entertain
people
and make lots of money while i do yeah
i'm proud of you man you're crushing it
yeah i i think would you would you want
to fight again this year like you've had
one it's early right yes i'd love to
have another two this year but as i say
i'm
i'm not pushing back into the cage and
the way i said before people say i
should take short notice fights no no i
shouldn't i don't have to take short
notice fatal
i'll take a fight with 10 weeks of prep
and i'll be the best me i've ever been
every time i do it short short side
fights
in the grand scheme of the ufc if you
look back they've never really yet it
never works out it never works out
you're rushing yourself you're not
prepared
the other guy's been in camp for 12
weeks he's in shape it never works out
man it's so short-sighted
so look again you got a good team around
here it's not like you know i'd love to
get another tip in this yeah but
at 55. yeah you take short notes fight
we're fighting [ __ ] izzy yeah let me
take a [ __ ]
okay
you say to sure no just fight it that'd
be 170 or 165 or something but [ __ ] they
win another three months you're fighting
first thing
i'm not a i'm not
i'm not big enough to fight at
170. yes the seven years were big yeah
yeah well like when i was in when i was
in new york for the
husband covington glad
oh kobe yeah yeah bumped into
derek brunson anthony smith uh your eye
hall and every one of them said to me
did you fight at 170. i was like no i'm
a 55 one of them was like what yeah
because i never standing next to them
i'm like the same height as some of them
like i'm saying height as brunson i
think
the idaho was a bit taller so was him
anthony smith but it didn't seem yeah
too much bigger than me but i know for
the fact he would be if we've got an
occasion
yeah and is the cat hard for you i mean
obviously you're not going to do this
every time
i think it's fun it's fun marketing it
shows your personality you're having fun
with it
but not everything i'm gonna try and not
do it every fight i'm gonna try but i've
had no guarantees though no guarantees
the past few fights i have done this
and i can't
this makes you love you even more me too
man seriously i think i haven't eaten
the soda because
when i start eating loud it's on it's on
like
both we do don't you don't understand
how much i actually eat like i didn't
even sign it over ten thousand calories
in a day
for the month
the monday or the tuesday after the
fourth i had eleven thousand calories
did you you went that is that when you
went to cheesecake factory no no this is
in the uk
i thought on saturday where are you
laughing monday or tuesday like eleven
thousand calories are you drinking gravy
i had like five thousand calories in
chocolate like whisper gold and
chocolate buttons and doughnuts and
cookies you never throw up no i know the
nando's rather about three thousand
calories in and a big breakfast savage
here's like 11 000 calories of here's
the thing dude and that was without
trying yeah and i support all this and
i'm proud of you doing this i support it
and it's going to work out for you right
now you're having fun when you retire
daddy and you keep eating like this
you look like fat bastard bro
i know it's me awesome get in my belly
yeah
you it's gonna be awesome though it's
gonna make you even funnier
all right
have you seen prince nasty mohammed
i respect it man
just to let yourself go and just get to
300 and not give a [ __ ]
laura wouldn't be happy about that like
bro your girl yeah yeah that's what you
signed up for though you don't yeah i'm
trying to for a fat kid
you're not that fast as long as you can
see you don't die
not that far
i mean that's science
that's science
that's science
that's not a bad rule to live by my man
that's not as long as you can see down
past your belly lab
are you gonna go eat after this
after this
yeah good that's just heavy yeah heavy
heavy good yeah even the potatoes are
good yeah i told you it was good man
well i know you got to uh no well you
got so many recommendations for them oh
yeah i got you dude for him he's heavy
yeah yeah i know i know you got to go
watch your uh home team liverpool play
today the mikey reds the mighty reds
both the [ __ ] reds up the [ __ ]
reds and they're playing uh manchester
united like to that big
game we hate united
i hate united why i just hate them isn't
it weird though yeah why would you hate
them just because from a different part
of the country you know what i'm saying
no because it all comes oh really
they're like you know what they're
they're your new york yankees right yeah
like they have all the money the big
spending that's the yeah
everyone
when it comes to basketball everyone
needs to leave us
when it comes to baseball everyone needs
the yankees
and when it comes to american football
liverpool and united just hate each
other we've got more major trophies than
any other club in the in england
liverpool liverpool and
i'm united we've got like one or two
more trophies down them but we're by far
the top two and they probably have more
money though yeah they have a lot more
money they spend a lot but not like you
guys not like city like city spend a lot
of money there
yeah they're our new rival
i'm not super we beat them the other day
they're only fake or final
i mean the f club semi-final
do you go to the games yeah
i always think about when i think of
those games they get something tuesday
before well i come here on tuesday and
the wednesday before i was in portugal
or tuesday before i was in portugal
watching liverpool play benfita went to
portugal to watch liverpool yeah
champions league called ridge i am
portugal only flying ryanair it's only
cost the flight was only about 100
something pounds
just like flying on a bin bag with wings
no water no no it's worse than jeff blue
lads watch me
no the bad one here is spirit man
spirit's the greyhound of the skies i've
never even heard of it yeah that's and
don't
i'm too successful to fly space sorry
spirit you suck
last question on soccer um football
when i think of premier league and stuff
like that maybe this american marketing
thing i'm sure it's a yankee thing is it
uh
i think of hooligans like there's
there's always the hooligans like you
know why you think that though yeah
movies they're filling greens dudes
they're what the film green state
oh no elijah wood plays an american
journalist that comes over to live with
his sister in london and he gets
involved in like
the the west ham hooligans
it's a load of [ __ ] the story like
but it's an entertaining watch known to
me yeah i'm sure it's nowadays
everyone always says that'll be from
america you know i know nowadays
hooliganism was like 30 years ago now if
you get caught i'm going to punch at a
football match you're getting like a six
year sentence and dependency can't do it
no
it's being it's been eradicated now if
you want to try and like fight for your
football you can't have that it's not
like you it's not like getting arrested
for the salt if you've got arrested for
the salt
get a slap on the wrist might get a
little sentence sure if you do it on a
football match it's not classed as a
souls it's class there's like a felony
yeah
yeah it's classed as like
attacking someone because of the team
the support
yeah
but that's how they're eradicated yeah
that's how they evaluated people who
were just getting given five-year
sentences and obviously there's no
i don't know any helicalism anymore what
goes on again obviously you're a sting
if you go to a different an away game
and you bump into their fans something
could happen
same here though 20 years ago there used
to be organized fights yeah where they'd
meet each other on a field and they'd
have a big screen style yeah but
nowadays that
yeah you're right i'll go to the [ __ ]
game well i know you gotta get going man
hopefully you enjoyed the burger i can't
tell you
what do you want to
you can finish dude you finished your
burger finished yeah i can't thank you
enough for doing the show
hope you enjoyed the uh burger hopefully
you make uh get in time to the the pub
to watch your team liverpool you thought
lots of time i thought you got this man
if you want more food just order it we
got you dude whatever you want brother
now that that's a good big look it's
[ __ ] good right if is it in the san
diego where yeah
what was it waggoo
swagger
this is a masterpiece yeah it was nice
man can't thank you enough brother also
san diego i'll be here july 21st 23rd
right now
this location man we needed a location
for patty so i hit up the left right i
said yeah we got patty here i said i
need to reserve they went say less
say yes we got you yeah we got you back
boy when i throw your name around people
they make it happen
but man appreciate you coming brother
i don't care man i don't want to get
[Music]
for the everybody boy
i need everything i get super thick boy